joining us now to discuss it all here in
Washington former UN Ambassador John
Bolton and Chuck Roach a former senior
adviser to the Bernie Sanders
presidential campaign and from Utah
former congressman and House Oversight
Committee Chair jason Chaffetz all right
I'm gonna go to you John first what is
your take on Trump in Pensacola
tonight he's on offense he's like happy
times are here again economy's role in
where Isis is on the run everybody
should be happier I want to bring both
sides together but there was a classic
Trump in rare form here well he's
certainly very energized for those who
say oh the burdens of the presidency
doesn't want it he's looking for that
way to get I didn't see any of that
tonight and I thought particularly the
lines on the economic growth in the
country we're a good foretaste of what
the election campaign is going to look
like in November of 2018 that he is
delivering that by removing the cloud of
more taxes more regulation that economic
growth has spurted and I think we'll go
on and just from my own point of view
when he talks about American sovereignty
it resonates and it resonates not just
with traditional Republicans it
resonates right into the heart of the
core Democratic constituency the
blue-collar vote and that's what wanting
the election in 2016 and if he can keep
that together he'll keep winning Chuck
let's go to you you work for Bernie
Sanders we're gonna play a Sanders
soundbite in a moment but Sanders run
ran on getting back to the heart of the
American work or the American people and
he kept saying tonight as he said before
I'm for the working man and for the
working people that forgotten people and
I say on this issue of trade where Trump
says I want to bring both parties
together
there are ways for some Democrats to
work with him on these trade deals and
the renegotiation of them and I know
everyone says we're not gonna work with
Trump but on that issue I think some of
the Sanders supporters could work with
Trump what do you think I've been doing
campaigns for 27 years and I grew up in
East Texas and went to work in a tire
factory when I was 19 the reason I
became a Democrat I started fighting
Bill Clinton in a trade agenda because
they sent my job to China where my
father worked and five of his brothers
it inspired me to get involved in
politics nobody my family had gotten
involved in politics you could only tell
by the way I've talked that nobody's
involved in politics
but you it resonates with a group of
people that I saw get motivated who had
never been motivated before traveling on
the road with Bernie and I think that's
why you probably saw some of the Bernie
Sanders supporters when it came down to
general election probably support Trump
the numbers bear that out right and
tonight sitting at home knowing that we
were going to talk about this I watched
this speech and I've prepared lots of
politicians for speech and he is at his
best when he's in this element but when
you get him out of that element he gets
on Twitter and it gets sidetrack
that's when we take advantage of it but
tonight he was at his best cuz that's
what he loves doing is rallying his base
Jason a lot of people today are talking
about how the the Republicans are you
know they're not going on offense enough
they're they're not hitting the Muller
probe which is filled with all these
Democrat partisans folks are saying come
on hit harder on this stuff the Clinton
did that very successfully against Ken
Starr and his man to prosecutors Trump
tonight seemed energized he didn't seem
someone who over the Senators meant to
lead the fish in he has dementia that's
what the whole MSNBC crowd has been
saying for months well I don't know that
anybody's even watching those other
networks that bears out in the numbers
but this is Donald Trump at his best and
it is about playing offense it is about
making America great and he's producing
results and that's what's showing up
when he talked about their 401ks that's
when he talked about home ownership in
in communities that haven't had high
home homeownership employment numbers
are doing well and I do think the
president needs to continue to play
office and offense and pound on that
wall I mean some of them the lines that
resonated the best is when the president
talks about securing our borders locking
down those borders and building the wall
and he thinks John that Roy Moore even
with the past allegations as horrible as
they are to so many people he needs that
Senate vote he needs the vote he needs
that support in the Senate for
everything he's doing yet could that
come back to bite him in 2018 and some
of these other close races well
certainly the Democrats are going to try
and make it come back look I find a real
irony here you know the most
straight-laced
the bigoted hardline people are all in
the belt buckle of the Bible Belt right
these people are so moralistic they just
they have no tolerance for anybody else
they're all going to vote for Roy Moore
next Tuesday but the open-minded
tolerant libertarian cosmopolitan people
in cities they're absolutely against him
there's a real inversion here and I
think what it reflects is the support
Trump has across the working-class vote
not just in the South but in the north -
I think people resent the political
correctness and that's what you're
saying all right now we're gonna play
Bernie Sanders from earlier today he was
on CBS this morning let's listen we have
a president of the United States who
acknowledged on a tape widely seen all
over this country that he assaulted
women so I would hope that maybe the
President of the United States might pay
attention to what's going on and also
think about resigning Chuck wasn't that
classic Bernie I mean he we saw Al
Franken forced out allegations that I
mean i if i were al franken I was
innocent of those allegations I wouldn't
I would stay there and fought it out and
I said on the show with Newt Gingrich I
think is outrageous that thirty senators
can push out someone who was elected by
the voters of Minnesota even though he
and I don't agree on anything but what
about this at Trump should resign
because of the Billy Bush tape but the
American people elected Trump they they
heard that tape
and I was disgusted by it frankly but
they heard that tape and they elected
him anyway what does that say about what
the American people in those key states
thought about the old ways of politics
that Donald Trump talked about tonight I
think you're talking about two different
things that I agree with partially is
that at a moment in time in politics
anything can happen
bernie is being Bernie Bernie's talking
to his base Bernie's doing smart
politics and as an advisor Bernie I
would always advise him to talk to those
people who were frustrated who may have
even voted for Donald Trump who voted
for nothing for us in the primary who
now may be feeling disillusioned about
one issue or the next
it's doing great Prabhat there's a
regular average working man feel that we
have to stop yeah it went up twice as
much under Barack Obama we didn't talk
about I think so because wages are
finally starting to crawl up the law
will agree with that we hadn't had real
wage growth in 21 years right I think
that the elections that were held a
month ago were another true barometer
when the Republicans got their clock
cleaned in Virginia is another snapshot
in time so if Democrats state now you
know the Republicans have but the
Republicans at a 17 seat majority in the
state has to be such a democratic seat
so the Republicans must have been doing
something there and they wiped that
slate clean so it's just a moment in
time snapshot so that's what made me
think well if the
Hannie was doing so well how did we do
so well when the Republicans had such a
majority one thing Jason that I thought
was interesting is what President Trump
said about what's happened in NATO since
he gave that speech urging NATO members
to pay their fair share he was smashed
by the elites for having them temerity
to actually ask other countries to pay
up this is what he said it helps them a
hell of a lot more than it helps us okay
and they should pay Germany's paying 1%
we're paying 4% explain that one to me
right and Germany has unsustainable cash
flow I read a report their cash flow is
unsustainable
so I said Angela I said I'm gonna send a
little of that cash flow our way and she
said but Donald because we're protecting
them we have 40,000 soldiers in Germany
nobody even knows that I said I'm gonna
let us have some she said Donald the
German people wouldn't be happy with
that I said well you know what the
American people aren't happy with the
way we have it now and at that point I
believe he said you know we've gotten
like 30 billion dollars more in the dues
that have been paid at NATO for you know
so we're actually getting more out of
this whole arrangement Jason I think
that is so powerful for people who think
why are we pay we're paying all the
money at the UN where we're not we're
not getting equal participation and
we're carrying a lot of load we're happy
to do it but people have to pay more I
thought that was a great moment it was a
great moment I can tell you I led a
congressional delegation trip 11 members
we traveled through a number of
countries that are allies in the United
States and I'm telling you to a tee
every single one of them led their
meetings with us by explaining to 11
members of Congress what they were doing
in order to pony up and pay more money
money that they knew was already do and
there is only one reason that happened
and it's because President Donald Trump
made it an issue he said it during the
campaign and he was following it through
and every one of those countries was
worried of
it because they have to have the United
States the military might of the United
States in order to survive and it is a
better fair deal and it's good for
America John I have to take a bite of
that Apple because he was trashed for
that he was saying an isolationist
you're not gonna do and he was going all
over the world that twelve twelve stops
in his Asian tour twelve date or excuse
me
China Vietnam Korea I mean this is not a
man who's afraid not afraid to travel
but he just wants to do more bilateral
trade deals and have a have a more
honest and open and fair relationship
with these concepts look I mean I think
the American foreign policy bureaucracy
is very hard pressed to say anybody ever
violates a treaty trade treaty arms
control treaty they do it all the time
and what Trump is said is we're not
going to let that go on that resonates
and he's right about it too that's how
you get to free trade